-How are you?
-I´m great. How are you?
-Good. It´s very nice
having you in the building.
-It´s exciting to be here.
30 Rock.
-We were talking backstage.
A lot has changed.
You went from a show
that was on at night
to now a show
that is on in the morning,
and you were saying backstage
you see your children
a lot more.
That must be nice.
-Yeah, it´s amazing.
I´m -- I´m having a totally
different experience with them.
I´ve gone from, "Hurry up!
Get your backpack!
We´ve got to go!"
to "It´s almost time for bed.
Come on. You´ve got
to brush your teeth.
Come on.
Here we go."
-That´s great. They must be
so much more into that.
-But can I tell you that
the nighttime routine
is much more rewarding
than the morning routine.
It´s just -- You know, like,
tucking them in...
-Oh, putting kids to bed.
-...reading the stories,
doing all that.
-Yeah. That´s so great
that you told me
the thing I miss every night,
doing this show is the --
-Sorry. Sorry.
-Yeah. It´s really cool of you.
I thank you so much for that.
-As they age up,
we´ll get more time.
-[ Voice breaking ]
God damn it, Megyn.
-I´m sorry.
-I didn´t need
to go through this tonight.
-There´s always FaceTime.
-[ Normal voice ] There´s other
changes from night to morning.
You´ve noticed,
in the very few short weeks
you´ve been doing your show,
there´s a lot more to do
in a morning show.
-You know, I´ve been amazed at
how much I have to move around.
-Yeah.
-I used to be able
to just sit at the desk
and look into the camera
and deliver the news.
And now it´s like --
I don´t know.
There´s, like, dried smoke
coming into the studio
and I got to walk down,
like, a runway,
and I got to -- I don´t know --
do yoga.
Uh, so you got to do
all that stuff,
and then you got to do
the serious interviews.
I mean, it´s the full gamut.
-Yeah.
Well, in that one,
I´ve got it over you,
because I just move
behind a desk
and just talk about the news,
so I --
-That´s so nice.
-Yeah, you might put your kids
to bed, but sweet desk.
[ Laughter ]
-Nailed it.
-Uh, you have --
You pointed out that you want
to talk about politics less
in your new job,
and I imagine
that you do not miss --
Or you can tell me.
Do you miss
talking to politicians?
-I really do miss
Mitch McConnell.
-Yeah.
-Desperately.
I miss our time together.
-He should come
on your morning show.
-Anthony Weiner.
Like, I -- No.
-You should make scones
with Anthony Weiner
on the "Today" show.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm.
Um...
-As, like, a work release.
-You know, it´s one of
those things, like --
Look, if a big hurricane comes,
we´re gonna talk about it.
But we´re not gonna be
The Weather Channel.
If something big happens
politically,
we´re gonna talk about it,
but I don´t want to do it
all the time
like I did on cable.
Because it´s soul-killing.
Um, so we´ll do it, you know,
where appropriate.
I just don´t want to do it
all the time.
Talking to, you know,
with all do respect,
to those guys, it´s --
Those are not the best
interviews, as you know.
-Yeah. Well, I -- You know,
tell me if you´ve found
the same thing.
I find -- And this is
across the aisle.
Republicans and Democrats
do it exactly the same.
Most politicians answer the
question they wish you´d asked.
And so, you ask the question
you want an answer to,
and the next thing you know,
you realize,
"Oh, this isn´t it."
-And they´ll take 12 minutes...
-Yeah.
-...to answer it.
-And then you get so bored
that you just give up.
-Right. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, that is one thing
that I would never do.
I mean, I always felt like --
and still do --
that I was there as the advocate
for the audience
and not for the guest.
So, I´m -- I´m not shy
about interrupting somebody
and sort of saying, "Boring."
But that doesn´t
make the experience fulfilling
when it´s over.
-Sure.
-And they´re still --
They´re spin masters.
-They are.
There´s a lot of spinning.